foreign
[Music]
[Music]
where do I even start Mike refuses to
leave ximena's house after she told him
to 150 000 times
I have work in the morning
plus Ximena reveals how they really met
which is something Mike didn't want us
to know he was out here trying to save
her period
don't save
her she don't wanna be the same oh talk
about drama let's get into it hey 90 day
fans fam it's Malicia before we chat
about Mike and Ximena which by the way
this is the lowest I've seen them go all
season it's a mess I mean I have some
quick updates for you to keep you in the
90-day Loop Memphis and Hamza are
officially husband and wife we're
married
and they're expecting a baby what
yep these two are excited about their
little one on the way a big congrats to
them but they now have to face reality
because Memphis is about to be pregnant
by herself in America while Hamza is in
Tunisia oh but wait until y'all hear
this Ben confronts mahogany about her
photoshopped pictures and when I come
here the pictures do look different you
know like it didn't look the same and
lying about her age you said you were 23
when I met you I don't remember
and this girl literally got up in the
middle of the conversation and walked
away from him I just need to go
I don't know why you're saying that
it's okay
and it looks as if he is still not
letting this relationship go I need to
tell you my heart and there's a point to
it
hold on hold on wait oh my gosh no she
did not go out the other door Let It Go
Let It Go did I pay the rent in this
house so I'm not leaving
all right
to get into this nasty fight
Mike and he
in here we ready
[Applause]
last episode Ximena broke up with Mike
and he felt the need to abruptly get up
and run away this episode started with
him still running oh Lord
[Music]
once he finally sits down Mike says he's
quote devastated that Ximena ended the
relationship
I thought it was real and he doesn't
know what he did wrong
everything she said on the first trip I
tried to fix myself
I just don't know what else more I could
do
this whole one-year relationship was all
over probably freaking money well if
that's how you start something Mike how
do you expect for its end
we'll dive more into that in a few in
the meantime Ximena says she ended the
relationship because she doesn't feel
good with Mike
she also says breaking up with him does
cause her to worry about her kids future
but she doesn't want to be unhappy so
she's choosing her happiness which
I guess is a good thing
Mike eventually returns to the
restaurant and Ximena asked what we all
wanted to know
why did you run
she's probably thinking see this is why
we are not going to be together
Mike goes on to apologize to Ximena for
taking off like that but she doesn't
have much sympathy for him she tells him
she doesn't want to see him hurt but she
also doesn't want him in her house and
he needs to leave tonight she even
offered to pay for the hotel what how
foreign
[Music]
Mike begs her to stay in another room at
the house and Ximena reluctantly gives
in I don't know why but after all of
this Mike is still holding on to hope
that this relationship can work I don't
even see why he wants it to work at this
point there is nothing good about it
once they get home he met a sister
notices Mike is sad but he tells her he
doesn't want to talk about it and he
goes upstairs to bed that's what Ximena
lets her know about his little run
foreign
please support
yeah
[Music]
I wanted to play that all the way
through because despite the fact that I
don't agree with ximena's behavior that
moment helped me see her and her
situation more clearly I don't know
about you but I've definitely come
across some Jimenez in my life young
women who have the responsibility of
holding their entire family's well-being
on their shoulders
aunties
he meant of using what she has in this
case her looks to support her family and
upgrade their lives
it's how she's doing it morally correct
uh no comment but she has a huge burden
to carry and if this is her way of
making it happen
it's her way
the next morning Ximena crushes any hope
Mike had less about fixing the
relationship when she returns the
engagement and wedding ring back to him
this is when
the fan why don't you keep the Rings and
guard them safe until we can work out
our differences
you do realize that you're losing the
best thing that you could have ever had
oh Mike is about to be that guy
that if it weren't for him she and her
children would be on the street hold up
hold up hold on
throughout this year and a half
relationship I was able to keep you
secure in a house so you weren't out on
the street with you and your children
now ximena's not perfect but Mike's
comment rubbed me the wrong way if
you're gonna do something nice for
somebody out of the kindness of your
heart you don't throw it back in their
face especially not on TV
Ximena tells Mike she would have found
another way to provide for her kids and
she can still work as a model that's
when he goes for a low blow and ends up
exposing himself what kind of modeling
job are you going to work for
where you're going to go back to that
adult
um internet job
that's a bombshell uh yep Ximena reveals
she really met Mike on an adult webcam
site when he previously told us he met
her on a dating app when I first got the
notification that I met I swipe right I
was just like wow this is really
happening I had to like pinch myself I
don't appreciate being Bamboozled like
that Ximena shares the whole story about
how it all went down and when exactly
Mike started financially supporting her
um
Como
Hawaii
he got on that webcam every day to see
Ximena
she probably made him feel like she
really liked him but that was her job to
do that and he fell for it tried to save
her and she hopped in the freaking raft
rescue
a daring rescue
Mike played into the money game now he's
upset that that's all she wants I want
to pull up this fan comment from
jwf0078 interesting name we're just
gonna go with Jay Jay says in part quote
sorry but he knew what he was signing up
for it was all a transaction
agreed if you're gonna use money or sex
to get a person how are you going to be
mad when they use you for it
make it make sense
if we were able to work out our
differences I could have opened up so
many opportunities for you I could have
helped you learn English to get better
jobs New York oh my man bow out with
Grace come on now Mike
Colombia
I never want to go to live in New York I
want to be in Colombia
why are you like this do you just want
me out of your life forever you don't
even care I'm not going to lie Mike's
mad face is pretty intense when all
we've known is sweet Mike and the red
collar shirt Ximena tells Mike she
doesn't know what else to say they can
be friends or enemies but he needs to
understand that it's over and he needs
to leave the house I have proof that I
pay the rent in this house so I'm not
leaving
no no
I have work in the morning
I said I don't give a damn clearly there
was
an emotional mic tells the producer he's
hurt that nothing else mattered to her
besides the money he was sending and
Ximena can go off and be an adult model
if that's what she wants to do she's a
mean evil cold [ __ ]
you have the puta
I'm not sure if he used that last phrase
in the right context
but we get the point Mike the argument
continues to escalate I just want to say
goodbye to the kids in the morning
you'll never see me ever again I promise
you if he's being honest I think that
that's very thoughtful and considerate
because he did tell the little boy he
was going to be his daddy
Papa
but Ximena wasn't hearing any of that is
[Music]
you might want to sleep with one eye
open no
[Music]
no no
ready
[Music]
oh that's the worst when you say
something bad to someone because you
thought they said something bad to you
but they did it
oh
[Music]
yeah
um
oh jimena's sister tells Mike he should
go to a hotel tonight and he can come
back to say goodbye to the family in the
morning
[Music]
so yeah
[Music]
if I go to a hotel can I still come back
tomorrow and say goodbye to your mom
your brothers and the children
see see I guess all the commotion woke
him in a sun up and this is the moment
that really broke my heart
let's get real I know it's easy to judge
Ximena but the truth is she's doing the
best she can with what she knows right
now so my intention with what I'm about
to say is not to look down on her in any
way I don't know her story other than
what we've seen on TV but one thing is
for sure the way her sons are seeing
their mom love and have all these
chaotic relationships is shaping who
they are going to become as adults in
this world and how they're going to
choose to love in relationships I just
hope Ximena learns to make better
decisions for herself and those boys
no one's perfect but it's time for her
to do better
um
[Music]
this was a hot mess
all right next week Mike is returning to
America but it doesn't seem as if things
are completely over between him and
Ximena
can we not
foreign
that was dramatic to say the least
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with E.T because we are covering
it all I will see you next time
foreign